to what Menachem adore we've been
waiting for you
Stephanie so welcome everybody to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast we have a very very special
guest very young if you ever seen a
hamster eat a ball of crack
that's what Stephanie sue is hello
welcome this really feels like I feel
like I'm in my element I feel like you
should have like a spread of food and we
could just like whisper do some ASMR
shall we eat I feel sleepy yeah I
actually do keep it very relaxing you
know what that feels like that's pretty
awesome
it feels like I have a have a mommy
that's like rubbing my head you know
what I mean I'm about to go to sleep do
ASMR yeah I try to I really do want to
start an ASMR podcast [ __ ] didn't so
[ __ ] bad because I listen to other
people's ASMR podcast stuff and it's
[ __ ] trash don't have good mics the
sounds terrible and the scenarios aren't
really great too because I like the ones
where they do where they pretend like
their massage therapist oh yeah these
days it's all about like robbing the
banks have you seen that one no likes
talking over their head and they're like
that's [ __ ] weird people happens but
weird that's different people aren't
sleeping there masturbate to that [ __ ]
that's a different style watch more on
twitch and I was mind blown because like
I don't know why but for ten minutes
straight this girl had a box like a like
it was like a headphone box right and
she had that [ __ ] you know that blush
brush she was just mixing that thing
going home yeah so good what's so good
about that no no you need to look up ear
licking your licking really does things
to me not like that but like you do go
to sleep
ear licking is the best thing I can
listen explain to me what the [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] freak
like it's like a double-sided headphone
and for some reason I don't know if it's
an earlobe cover or have headphones no
no the mic the mic not headphones I'm
sorry the mic looks like earlobes and
they'll like stick q-tips in it and then
like and then they'll like clean your
ear and then they'll just like lick it
and I'm like damn this is this is
channel on YouTube that I watch but I do
understand that q-tip type of [ __ ]
because there's this channel where these
Korean dudes go to Vietnam I'm pretty
sure they get their dicks out there too
but they go there to get like these to
get a full on just spa day and it's like
super cheap in Vietnam but they get like
their fingernails clip their toenails
clipped full-body massage they get
shampooed facial and they clean their
ears out like in a very very unique way
with like 12 different tools and I used
to watch that [ __ ] to help me go to
sleep
did they do it like a it's my style they
go to this spa I want to say it's a
Marcel because it's still kind of noisy
in there but I guess it's just that
whole experience because there's this
other guy called the ASMR barber and he
just gets like his like he expanded out
into massages and [ __ ] but it used to
just be like Indian head massages that
used to get and you've seen that have
you seen any of her massages they just
literally beat the living [ __ ] I don't
know but they like rub your head [ __ ]
crazy and they start stocking you upside
your head yeah it's pretty [ __ ]
amazing I should know this seems more
like a kink then a smart empathy I feel
you would know more about this type of
stuff just because you're [ __ ] weird
dude I feel like I should and like the
food niche is kind of like that it's my
niche these days but I don't know
anything about anything the world is
always interesting to me because I mean
we we even did one on your channel I see
some stupid mop box down but your
mukbangs I wouldn't even consider them
so high quality like they used to stress
me the [ __ ] out cause it was like a
cooking show and like you're like Food
Network yeah it's different I was so
stupid though because I had this like
this mental concept of like oh that's
how you do
bungs [ __ ] watch mine and then I just
beat myself into oblivion you're a
goddamn artist man yeah you always got a
next-level [ __ ] I got an extra camera
dude we got three camera setups we're
gonna light the [ __ ] up good thanks man
you fed me sushi I was like I was like
I'm not gonna even order food bro I'm
gonna [ __ ] make that food dude
idiot so tiring so amazing I wish you I
mean I don't wish that you continued
them because obviously you were
stressing over them but they were so
good they made our community look good
for sure I mean if I ever did it again
it was if if I have more time I probably
would do it again but it was so
exhausting first of all making sushi one
of the [ __ ] hardest things I've ever
done in my [ __ ] life man
just the knife skill alone was so
difficult
I ruined so many pieces of like sashimi
but I just ended up chopping it up and
making the hand rolls anyways and then
everybody else got to eat him but that's
why the handles that I was serving was
the slices that I would [ __ ] up on and
so I would take that chop it up and put
it into like little hen rolls and it was
so good because what's it like like
living in the brain of a perfectionist
because I feel like I'm the total
opposite well - [ __ ] let it go part
of your appeal because I think like
people like the fact that you're just
this crazy person and that's just really
who you are like whatever you guys see
on her muff bugs I've been on her love
long before with this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
insane she's rambling like a maniac
that's just how she is this is who she
is and I say on and off the camera she's
that's why we all love her is cuz you're
not fake you are we walk yeah the same
mukbang creature that I see is the same
one that goes to dinner with me is the
same how did you get started in muck
bogging oh my gosh okay like do you want
like the basic [ __ ] version grid girl
we're here to talk I want to know cuz I
don't even know this story okay this is
a long story it started in elementary
school what record yourself in Elemento
that's so creepy no suddenly like CPS is
that my mom
it started in elementary school because
I cry when I watch people eat alone
which is so crazy because a lot of
people really genuinely enjoy eating
alone Japanese people you watch people
eat alone and you get yes in the drama
it doesn't matter you die someone dies I
don't give a [ __ ] but if there is a
scene in a diner where an old man like a
Naja she is eating alone it freakin
breaks my heart into like a bajillion
piece cry when you're in Japan as a
little kid you would cry I would cry
like ball and then like there was this
one moment I don't know if this was like
a shifting moment at all but uhm there
was like this teacher that I hated in
elementary school and then I walked past
her classroom one day like when
everybody else was like out like recess
bla bla bla and I'm like roaming the
hallways the dirty streets and I saw her
eating alone and she's probably really
enjoying her time like [ __ ] these kids I
finally get some time alone and I loved
her after that like I felt like she
still hated me but I was like you know
what miss is not alone you lose you
wrote your own story she's probably like
I could breathe now I could this creepy
little Korean girl staring at her she's
trying to enjoy her [ __ ] meal she's
like leave me alone dude from Atlanta
and then I had quit my job as working
retail I was like bouncing back and
forth between like 25 different retail
stores cuz I I kept becoming on the
verge of getting fired so I quit before
I leave gracefully and then I realized
that like I should have gotten fired
because my sister was like you should
have filed front employee I was like
that's kind of smart yeah but I didn't
and so I was like in between jobs well
good for you were not taking advantage
of the government it's like 25 times
yeah and then and then I was the one
eating alone
and that was like wow that made you sad
that made me not like sad but just like
it felt really empty yeah cuz my fiancee
was at work and like all my friend well
I didn't really
have friends too and then like all of
them were co-workers in the raw work and
they're like oh that's the girl that
almost got fired let's not hang out with
her there's a lot of [ __ ] people here
especially where you were living at oh
yeah oh yeah the Westside and so I
started watching mukbangs I was like
this is this is my porn and I didn't
tell anyone it was like my dirty little
secret
like it made you sexual or you just be
like thank you know when I first started
watching maybe two years ago it was more
about like the quantity of food more
than anything
so yes yeah people who were eating like
just ten in-and-out burgers back to back
to back to back to back you know and
that's why I was like okay this is
obviously not something I should
broadcast to the world that I loved
doing or watching and then one day I got
so bored I went to Whole Foods and I
picked up a frozen burrito like the
organic one it's not even good I don't
know why and I put it on this big-ass
tray because everybody was using big-ass
trays but like one burrito on a big-ass
tray and then I had my phone my iPhone
and I put it on a selfie stick but those
don't those aren't tripods so I had to
like balance it behind on books so I
could get the good I struggled in on
double chin and then I actually was
putting my feet to hold the selfie stick
I'm talking too much oh yeah this is
what I read through this like Chinese
filter app but to make me look cute you
know Oh like the face but it was like
too cheap to pay for the premium version
so there's like Chinese characters Todd
anyone cuz this is embarrassing I only
told my fiance I didn't even show and I
was like don't look at it like you can't
even look it up because I'm so smiling
and then um the next morning I woke up
and I had 42 views and you made it and I
was like okay mister you have viral my
duty to give these 42 people more you
know like this what they came for
that's tight yeah and then so well it's
just an interesting thing about your mug
is that it's not about the quantity of
food really it's just the people are
actually just there to hear you [ __ ]
just talk right cuz you just you talk
about literally anything and everything
which at which people you would be
[ __ ] surprised when you look at
somebody who does is then you go oh
that's easy
yeah you tried talking to yourself for a
[ __ ] hour dude every day you have to
Bob different [ __ ]
exactly you have to be a [ __ ] insane
human being like this person to be able
to do that because that's why I can't
even do daily vlogging cuz I I just I
have so many thoughts but I don't know
how to translate it to the camera where
I asked it you have to believe that
you're an interesting person which you
very much are you're a [ __ ] weirdo
like it's a skill right it's [ __ ]
difficult because a lot of the times
when people see somebody on that space
they go oh [ __ ] why can't why I should
just do that it's like you wish [ __ ]
you wish you could [ __ ] that's
true like people make it seem so simple
like oh they're just eating food and
talking it's like shut the [ __ ] up you
don't even know yeah it's actually quite
difficult to get the lighting set up
okay guys please respect our art the
difficult part is like eating and
talking cuz sometimes I'm so into the
food I just forget oh oh yeah you guys
are still there yeah this podcast is
brought to you by purple my friends if
you don't know what purple is purple
makes the best mattresses on the market
because that thing will caress your body
like nothing else don't you dare bless
your body with nothing else but a purple
mattress because it won't be a blessing
because it's not a purple mattress a
purple mattress is both soft and firm at
the same time it's hard to explain but
it's something that you need because you
don't want it too soft and you don't
want it too firm and much like that
porridge Sun you want it just right
purple mattress by the way is also
developed with some rocket science
technology and that's not me biessing
that's some real stuff and if you want
to try it out check it out there's a
hundred night a risk free trial if
you're not fully satisfied you can
return your mattress for a full refund
that's insane backed by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and re turns
you're going to love purple and right
now my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide just
text brain to eight four - eight eight
eight the only way to get this repo is a
text brain - eight four - eight eight
eight
that's be are a I and eight four eight
eight eight where did you grow up in
Atlanta Georgia Atlanta Georgian I'm
Atlanta Georgia and I'm not proud it's
hot Lana baby we talking about the
strippers with big booties home he was
talking about Magic City who me that's
why she's in California I think yeah her
souls always been a California girl I
think so and my voice has always been a
valley girl and like everyone talks like
me and like a basic [ __ ] is easier
there's a lot of Korean people on that
Lana though yeah which is why I love it
could you move to LA [ __ ] the [ __ ] the
area that I grew up in was such a
secluded area and I grew up in such a
community that was very opposing
anything that wasn't like them and so
like last I think the last month I went
to Lana oh my god was it last month I
could not like I was shaking in Atlanta
why I have such a strong like negative
emotion associated with the place that I
was raised that when I go back like I
physically feel sick and like why were
you like bullied and [ __ ] yeah but I
mean like everybody was so you know
depending on what type of bullying it
was I mean yeah I did it can bring back
some bad memories and [ __ ] yeah I mean
there was some intense ones I think it
was mainly like I was bullied by really
unfortunate people okay that sounded
wrong so I was bullied by like church
leaders I mean you really shouldn't be
bullied by church leaders that happens
at all churches girl
sometimes Korean churches I heard can be
a little bit difficult this is not all
churches obviously but no but it's I
think that's Japanese and Korean culture
is very similar we amazing there's a
high yeah there's a there's a fine line
between hazing and bullying and
sometimes it gets overboard yeah but
it's also a rite of passage yeah in our
culture which is kind of bad and toxic
but it happens because I when I started
making Chinese friends I was like oh
thank god I could breathe in these
Chinese they don't [ __ ] bull you the
way that we do know so it's like oh my
god and I don't have to [ __ ] in this
guy's two years older than me but it's
fine oh my god thank god he's not giving
me a [ __ ] wedgie yeah for sure yeah
it was nuts no my pastors this is not an
emotional topic guys okay because I have
learned I have progressed I am new again
I am still a hoe so no when I was in
high school obviously like you fall into
like bad habits sometimes bad influences
and I ended up losing my virginity for
the first time and it was a very
traumatic experience I did not love it
you know but who does and then I told my
pastor's wife because I was like I can
confide in her she seems like you know
condemned you didn't she she she acted
there's not a drink of emotional water
it's let me get ready to tell you I got
a cottonmouth okay let's do this
so I confided in her and like the way
that I did it wasn't like oh yeah matter
of fact this happened it was like hey I
feel really like confused you know I
don't know like am I gonna go to hell
like what's happening I want to live
should I tell my mom
and so I confided like that in at first
she was like very understanding she's
like no I mean thank you for telling me
blah blah blah and then she's like why
don't we go out we're gonna get all the
girls together and we're just gonna talk
things through you don't have to talk
about you know what happened to you but
we're just gonna all talk about it we
open conversation and so we go into the
room this was Sunday and all the girls
are in there and I feel like everyone
knew is kind of about me because I was
already like crying at that point
and she has this giant roll of like
[ __ ] Costco size kitchen size
aluminum foil and she hands out of
sheets every girl right and she's like
it's beautiful it's shiny its shimmery
look at it in the light blah blah blah
poetic [ __ ] and then um she crumbles it
and she's like now everybody crumble it
this is Stephanie yeah she's like
crumbly and so I crumbled mine
everybody's crumbling there's and then
she goes okay now try to get it back to
where it was and then so we're all
unfolding it we're doing that thing
against like the tables where we're
trying to like yeah then she's like
it'll never be the same
that's your virginity taken away pretty
much you know why you little fatty
[ __ ] I'm sorry just kidding should
probably not a thought probably is oh
yeah but that is so rude and how old
were you I was in high school so she was
making an example out of you yeah it's
like everyone knew and guess what
everyone
mm-hmm well you know one of us here
piece of 40 yeah the [ __ ] crazy thing
about that [ __ ] is is like you guys have
to realize like I grew up in a church my
father's a pastor I was a youth minister
you there are so many people and this is
not to represent the whole religion I
don't like doing blanket statements like
that but what happens with a lot of
individuals is like they are tracked
pieces of trash themselves so they have
to try to bring somebody else down to
make them feel better about how
sufficiently it is I'm saying and it
happens a lot in churches too because
there's not Christ it's this whole fear
of like they almost want to highlight
somebody else's shame to hide there's
right so and I guarantee you to like
dude there are so many people that want
the church just for [ __ ] [ __ ] man
like a [ __ ] I'm telling you man
straight up dude there was a bunch of
[ __ ] thugs that came to church
because they wanted to [ __ ] every Church
girl and guess what they [ __ ] them but
these were the same [ __ ] girls that
were there at every Bible study talking
about I'm still a [ __ ] virgin that's
a [ __ ] I saw a picture of you sucking
his dick what are you talking about
[ __ ] ho but they had the audacity and
the gall to go up in front of everybody
and talk about how important it is to
keep their virginity let me tell you
some [ __ ] other crazy [ __ ] right so I
know there's other other girl actress
like former YouTube or some [ __ ] right
and mind you I know about
her specifically because I know guys
that have [ __ ] her right and they know
about her like crazy tendency so you
know word gets around real easy
especially with [ __ ] Korean people
they they [ __ ] talk everybody's ears
off so we were at this [ __ ] gala
event and she was there hey and this
[ __ ] is so [ __ ] funny man like I'm
sitting there and mind you I know one of
my best friends is the guy used to hook
up with her all the [ __ ] time and
then we're sitting and we're eating and
she's behind me and I hear her talking
and she goes she's talking to the girl
she goes yeah I'd like I don't really
believe in sex before marriage she goes
like I think it's completely ok for
people the way and I [ __ ] spat my
drink out I was [ __ ] 1970 spit-take
and the funny thing is that girl never
asked her if she was a virgin she just
voluntarily put that information now she
goes oh I'm a virgin
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] ho nobody asked you
with your loose ass [ __ ] like nobody
[ __ ] it but I'm saying like and she
is like one of those holier-than-thou
people talks about oh man I'm I'm this
church leader I I love doing praise
because I want to put God first it's
like yo man you could say whatever you
want and if you really are Christian and
you do believe that God is really this
omnipotent being you could lie to
everybody in this room but you ain't
lying to God so what's the whole point
you know crazy no I'm totally crazy
you know I can't believe some she
actually did that [ __ ] you know what to
be honest with you it's kind of funny
from the kitchen she thought of this she
did like that's a good one just like I
would I wish I went to that church I
would call everybody god I've been like
[ __ ] Esther I know you suck this
guy's grace I know you suck [ __ ]
John's dick I know you did it right
behind the [ __ ] Pew you [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass hoe Jenny don't even act like
you don't [ __ ] watch porn I know you
do you've been masturbating I smelled
your fingers [ __ ] huh I know what's
up all you [ __ ] dirty ass [ __ ] I
don't like it when people is so funny
because that's like the most fun
christ-like thing to do
to sit and then judge other people for
their sins it's like the worst I mean
and what is she learning from that
exactly it's like okay so your virginity
is gone so you committed this diabolical
sin now what now what the [ __ ] are you
supposed to do hey everyone let's rub it
in each other's let's rub it in her face
that she just lost her virginity did she
call you out or she just made you but
like I mean I feel like everybody has
like what is it called in English like
nudity like yeah I mean you know it's
about me I'm like the only one with
bloodshot tears we were talking prior to
all that I think all the other girls
were virgins too I know that one of them
weren't yeah I would have called
everybody out I was like because you're
a little bit of oil not crumpled babe
where they all afterwards was there a
point like did they get together and
talk about their losing the virginity or
anything it was just like symbolism yeah
it's like you are crumbled poet spoiled
that's that's all you are
that's so funny because even that right
there is very unchristian like there's
nothing in the Bible that says that once
you're tainted guy will never love you
so what in the [ __ ] are you talking
about [ __ ] you are gonna be the first
person to go to hell and God's gonna
have a [ __ ] piece of aluminum foil
and he's gonna pass it to your Korean
ass I need to buy crumpled it my child
that's you and he's gonna throw it down
to [ __ ] waste backs that goes
straight to hell and she's gonna go
right there - it's so funny that she had
she was thinking so hard for what
symbolism works and she came out with
foil it's kind of genius it is genius
because it did stick with me for a hot
second and I completely went I mean I
don't know if she did this on purpose I
mean you like have to know right but
like I completely after that I was like
done with Church I was like I'm gonna go
hang out with these kids who are like
the opposite of Church but then the
funny thing is like I'm sitting there
okay what are we doing here crumbling
before okay we're trying to get it back
to normal like and then she goes that
your virginity I wouldn't even do this
if this is what you're gonna do dude
yeah was she was she married yeah she
was Gina
one that pastor is also going to hell -
she's completely cheating that I know it
I those are yeah and it's such as
Jezebel way of doing things about that
sucks to that you actually trusted her
enough to confide in and she [ __ ]
threw it in your face like backstabber
you [ __ ] [ __ ] back I hope you're
watching this right now if I ever
[ __ ] see you in the middle of the
street I'm kicking you in your [ __ ] I'm
doing a [ __ ] upper [ __ ] on your ass
why is it that there are more Satan's in
church than there are Jesus's they call
Church the hospital for the sick and you
know it's like people like that are the
ones who need Church the most it's just
that it's so it's like the same is
running Church
it sucks cuz they don't get called out
on that [ __ ] but that's why people never
like me in church I call that [ __ ] up
with a quickness
I'd be like you don't do that [ __ ] it
was I think that's one of the reasons
why I left a church - cuz I loved going
there seeing my friends eating like but
the way that they were bullying my mom
your mom yeah cuz you know what's crazy
they bullied my mom to like well that
was a problem kid so like like the same
situation it was easy for them to be
like look at that family look at them
how unchristian like instead of getting
together and helping and it's like it's
more like let's ridicule them and then
pray for them and talk [ __ ] about them
and man it was my other family members
too like they were going through a hard
time and they they looked at the church
for help and then they said hey we need
to borrow some money and they all looked
at him as if like they're trying to scam
them and but they gave so much to the
church they gave so much to other people
and when they needed help it they looked
at them as if like you're just trying to
scam us I'll pray for you that's friggin
nuts it is right okay on the topic of
borrowing money have you guys ever gonna
let friends money I don't believe in
lending money
I believe that my freshers suffered no
and that's not a case I've done it I
don't I don't lend money I give money so
like what I mean by that is that my
father always told me since I was
younger he goes if you have enough money
and you're financially stable enough to
give somebody money that means you're
also financially stable enough not to
ask for it back so if you're in a
situation where you all house Christian
like if you're in a situation where you
give money and then you're worried about
your own savings account don't give that
money on the first place he goes just
tell them that you can't help them out
but if you can't give it out that means
you are acknowledging the choice that
you may never see that money again
because it makes friendship weird yeah
so no no I I want it to be weird
uncomfortableness no I like it
you know why anymore this podcast is
brought to you by Mac well then Mac
Weldon believes in smart design premium
fabrics and simple shopping Mac Weldon
will be the most comfortable underwear
socks shirts undershirts hoodies and
sweatpants and more that you will ever
wear they have a line of silver
underwear and shirts that are naturally
antimicrobial as well I have my own Mac
Weldon gear my friends and I'm gonna
tell you a couple of things about the
website it's super clean super easy to
use shipping is extra fast and on top of
that I gotta say I look flying the stuff
specifically I look flying the stuff man
I said something about shipping it
wasn't even part of the point it's not
that again this podcast mmm this podcast
is brought to you by Mac Weldon my
friends Mac Weldon believes in smart
design premium fabrics and simple
shopping and I got to tell you it will
be the most comfortable underwear socks
shirts undershirts hoodies and
sweatpants and more that you will ever
wear listen I got some Mac Weldon stuff
I got two Mac Weldon sweats
some of the best looking swim trunks
I've ever put on my naked body in my
life and on top of that I got that math
Weldon cute little sweet sweet wallet I
like simplicity I like high quality
stuff and I don't like to walk around
with a lot of flashy stuff looking for
attention and Mac Weldon has a lot of
fashion basics with great design great
quality and great technology so I love
Mac Weldon get your stuff so check it
out so for 20% off your first order
visit Mac Weldon calm and enter promo
code GB at the checkout once again for
20% off your first order visit Mac
Weldon comm and enter promo code GB at
checkout to get that 20% discount baby
ok so check this out I used to [ __ ]
test people all the time because I
wanted to see their character I loved
seeing people's true character right so
like if people
ask me for money I keep tabs I want to
make sure that this person is honorable
or else why am i spending time being
this person's friend so you have like a
whole ice booklet of like I mean my head
right and I also used to sell drugs so
it was easy for me to kind of like keep
tabs okay
and I liked lending things to people cuz
that was like I know this person is good
he's gonna pay me back this person takes
a long time but he will pay me back this
person's a lying scoundrel never pay me
back okay I don't want to be this
person's friend oh I didn't if I come
and if I can ask for the money back
it gives me opportunity to see how they
respond so it's just maybe I'm just
weird but I like testing people's morals
a lot so much just happened in that
couple of sentences I'm a drug dealer
this is life scoundrel to somebody are
you money philosophy though like yeah I
pretend as if like it's gone you know
like I don't I don't get all bent like
oh [ __ ] man I need that money like why
did you pay me back it's fine well cuz
why is it for you because you're doing
real really well for yourself people
coming out the woodwork well no yes yeah
success right people feel like they they
are entitled to your success right the
answer's [ __ ] no no they know that
I'm not successful people ask me for
money they already know if I say no it
is what it is like it's like do people
ask me multiple times for money man and
they're like yo get me get some money
and I nicely the same answer if I don't
like them especially I'm like why the
[ __ ] would I give you money is exactly
ways are more successful than I am oh
that's true
I mean it's weird because like there's
people friends I have given money if I
calculate it out like there's one guy I
know I probably give it at least like
six or seven G's in the span of like why
you make so many mistakes you only takes
one for me well for him
what prohibit was never alone though
like I said like I had excess of money
and I gave it to him I guess he was
struggling and I always saw him work
hard it's just like you know the career
that he's in it's just not it's not
viable that money is always gonna be
around the corner so it's like for him
if he if I saw that he wasn't working
really hard and he wasn't really getting
anywhere it's like you're not getting
this [ __ ] money you're not gonna do
anything with it but there's also
somebody else who I've also lent money
before and I saw that he bought a
big-screen TV the next day and I and you
best believe that I went up to him I was
like returning that [ __ ] TV back and
give me my money back
how do people have the balls we're
stupid
that ko who knows yeah and then it's odd
too because we talked about the students
like if we if we ever won the lottery
people like what happens when people ask
you for money there's a very very famous
word in the Bible it's called no ask me
for money because the word is no say no
when people ask you for money it's hard
it's a hard thing because you do you owe
them is I think I would have a problem
saying no if they've helped me in the
past exactly like oh man when I was down
and out you paid twenty thousand or
whatever for me and I'm like you know
what I want to do something for you
interesting that is very different like
yeah we've been friends for how many
years yeah well my situation is not so
much like that but more just like yeah I
have this like guilt of uh you know do
you guys get that I was like okay well
you guys have been in the industry for
so long it's like full-fledged youtubers
but like your life is like too good so
like share the good no for this [ __ ]
everybody else that's lazy hard for this
[ __ ] to be honest with you like how I
view it is this right let's say like I'm
doing really well
right and they go whoa you probably have
mind to spare it but if I have money to
spare it why the [ __ ] would I give it to
you I get to my parents I guess I give
it to family people that need it that
are close to me and also like I've
donated yeah so and also know your
[ __ ] place in my life like you know
for [ __ ] I want to give you money so why
the [ __ ] would you ask yeah I like
treating people oh me too yeah but
that's different from giving yeah yeah
cuz it's like yo I'm like yeah like I'm
in debt Bella blah I need like six grand
it's
like you know there's other ways other
people for you to ask besides me cuz I'm
not gonna give it to you specifically
because this depends on the relationship
with the person right it's like if I
don't really if I don't really [ __ ] with
you like that and we barely talk to each
other there might be a time in my mind
that I'm gonna need that money or on top
of that my parents might need that money
or my really good friend I like actually
like that I actually like buying that
money so your your inability to save
money and the fact that you made poor
decisions shouldn't take away from the
money that I might give to somebody else
that needs it that I actually care about
so what's an example that you I'm very
curious I mean I don't have friends like
this well you know what's crazy I don't
have friends but suddenly I got a lot of
friends that are not your friends
they're not your friends girl give me an
example how do they ask we're like what
well so sometimes it's just straight up
asking just straight up asking because
they have student debt and I didn't um I
don't know no no no like someone that I
actually like like maybe a couple
birthdays together that's it yeah and
they'll ask and then like for me I'm
like I I feel like I'm going through a
phase I don't know if it's a phase or if
I'm gonna be like this for the rest of
my life but I am gonna do you give it to
them no I don't good only because my
fiance's wild of course yeah yeah he
wasn't around you probably would have
yeah be such a sweet soul I just don't
like feeling like I have something and
you don't and so like I feel like it
could be a situation where like you know
when you have surplus you don't really
use it you know well here's the thing
right like you're young you don't know
what the surplus means because I just
have the same philosophy yeah until I
got sued until my family went bankrupt
until all these emergencies happened and
it's like hey man I saved 40 50 thousand
it took me years to go do this but it
all disappeared because I was rescuing
my family and friends right so when that
happens you're like wow no wonder you
need extra money you just don't know you
don't know if some family member needs a
[ __ ] lung transplant it's gonna cause
$100,000 and you could come to the
rescue
you don't know about a lot of [ __ ] also
too with the
got done with that [ __ ] and you needed
to help do you think they give you that
money back exactly exactly so [ __ ]
dumb people like that their mentality is
you're doing good
Michael supply it's gonna take me ten
years or whatever like I've been around
these [ __ ] yeah you know what happens
is that these [ __ ] all talk together
right so yeah yeah so you're like you
know what this girl gave me this much oh
really let me make let me [ __ ] be her
friend and I'll ask her for some money
ha and then let me get this other person
to come down I've seen it time and time
again too [ __ ] nice people that work
[ __ ] hard there are leeches girl you
got to watch out you got to smell out
which ones are the [ __ ] leeches and
stomp on them I wish a [ __ ]
would ask me for that time like you know
I got student loans that's crazy
egg go go to your house and you'll find
a nice package and they'll open it up
it'll be a nice FedEx box they'll open
it up black and gold lettering it's
intimidating dude you got to be a better
bait oh yeah inside that box is gonna be
a [ __ ] huge turd this girl she's talk
she talks to everyone she's nice as [ __ ]
like she's a easy target like if I
[ __ ] started crying to you about I
can't make my house payments in a
heartbeat I need $10,000 really if it
wasn't for my fiancee I would just be
Stephanie I need $10,000 please give it
to me now after this podcast I'm gonna
ask you for $10,000 and I'm going to buy
another TV I know why do you feel guilty
that you work hard um because you know
it's crazy I feel like in high school I
didn't feel this way at all I feel like
I I don't know if it's me getting older
tell me but you guys have been in LA for
a really long time right we you grew up
your oh yeah in the Bay Area right so I
feel like Valley Sacramento oh and so
where I grew up it was very sheltered
and I didn't like go downtown Atlanta a
lot it was like a very like not really
uppity uppity but like
like middle upper class area and so I
just felt like every little thing was
like whoo boo who me right and then I
get here and it's like especially
downtown it is so difficult oh you went
to skid row didn't you you drive two
blocks away and then you realize holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] like my life is literally
peonies and daisies up my [ __ ] and
like I am sure there's a ton of people
who work just as hard if not harder
making way less money so I do feel like
I have like this feeling of like like I
think just the sheer fact that like we
can like like what we do is already like
a blessing I mean I think you're a very
very nice person but I think the thing
that you're missing out on is that
people will take advantage of your
kindness and that's not me being
somebody who is jaded I'm talking about
that's just how human beings are and
we've all been taking advantage of
exactly so it's like if it's happened to
about nine out of ten people I don't
think you're the exception to that rule
yeah right so you're feeling you're
feeling empathy and guilt which is cool
right it's a human being you guys know
yeah right but at the same time you also
have to think about yourself as number
one this is actually - your age you're a
very young girl and as an adult the
stuff starts to go away because you
start to realize how life actually is
right you start to realize like number
one how important that money that you
gave away is or who you could have given
it to or what you could have created
with it now mind you if you were a
bajillion there oh yeah that's a
different story but did not yeah you
know what I mean not it but you do well
for yourself but you ain't that fun
you're still growing all the money that
you do have you cannot solve the world's
exact problem it's not on your shoulders
you know and at the end of the day you
you're the one that's eating and making
these videos so deep - so not default it
was like so like you know good for you
Stephanie you're the one shoving tacos
in your face did you deserve it
I was the one eating [ __ ] bugs I'm
just kidding party dessert I'll tell you
this like if I could just shove my face
waxen never mind I did that for a living
what you should do to make yourself feel
a little better is give back to your
fans to the direct people that love you
like who the [ __ ] cares about these
strangers you can give a [ __ ] about them
when you're a bajillion there and you're
80 years old right then you can start
being like [ __ ] Bill and Melinda
Gates but I don't know maybe I'm cold or
what what happens when you get older is
what's awesome is when you're young you
have a you have this more social
obligation you feel like all right man I
got do something I got power I have
money I have a limo I can see my
privilege I can see I'm just a little
bit above these people but then you
start to realize that guilt is for is
from something else it's it's so deep
about it right the reason why you feel
bad is because you feel guilty that
you're above them if everybody in your
world was just as successful just as
know just as loved then you don't
realize like they're just reminding you
where you are in the world and then
you're just like off [ __ ] yeah I'm see
what you're feeling isn't we call
survivor's guilt right so it's like yeah
survivor's guilt was a feeling it's like
I have I live in in in abundance right
and sometimes to just by based on what
people say about what you do as a career
they go you you visit yourself these
people work just as hard maybe more how
come they're not as fortunate as me and
you kind of get sucked into this like
thought of like I maybe I don't deserve
all this stuff maybe I do give it up
give it up that's kind of like what I
feel like I feel like I'm extremely
undeserving of what I have I know I
could tell them but the way that you
talk about yourself and it's not the
case like like I said yeah you like my
[ __ ] too and I feel like you're guilty
about not liking
like my [ __ ] shut up you're conflicted I
think it also comes from you know being
raised Christian and you're supposed to
be humble and all that stuff and then
it's like but I like nice [ __ ] and then
and then and then you you're going
through this inner conflict of that man
I always say about myself right for me
personally I say I add the mouth of
Satan but everything else is Christian
is [ __ ] I got it
broke-ass [ __ ] you know my [ __ ] I'm just
I just got this dirty ass [ __ ] mouth
man I'd be [ __ ] helping people out
all the time
yeah I'm saying but this this mouth just
Satan controls that's all you know
Diablo I'm sorry I know one of my
favorite [ __ ] games until my account
got hacked yeah in high school I thought
Diablo was another way of saying that
someone was playing with their little
like dick you thought that was
masturbating yeah because all the dudes
it kind of we played Diablo I say such a
weird what did you say that your first
time that you lost your virginity was a
terrible experience was it whoa I mean
he was just really mediocre Oh first
time no it wasn't his first time that's
my first time either way we're when
you're oh let me just tell because in
defending him I'm also defending myself
when I was a nice girl
we just talked about the last podcast my
dick game whack is [ __ ] I don't know
what was going on and it took multiple
times and it took a angry Filipino that
was like I was like how was that she
goes man I was i [ __ ] to be met i hold
you and you break this down they helped
you oh for sure yeah neg better and
become better she said man yeah she
didn't like it much she [ __ ] that she
[ __ ] a lot of dudes though so she she
kind of understood what was going on I
was actually her first Asian boyfriend
there are so many bombshells that you
guys keep just dropping on me I'm
soaking
but I think with high schoolers it
mainly has to do with the fact that like
you guys hype me up too much you know
like you gas yourself up and then you're
like oh my god like I'm gonna climb
Mount Everest and then it's like
literally a speed bump and you're like
God why did I bring my harness my
suspension like all of these things like
three seconds or something yeah and then
you're like that was just a rough maybe
you have really good Eagles you have
really good grip on your [ __ ] guys
dicks are sensitive when they're like
hella young
hello Stephie once' love you very much
see a bumpy dicks yeah find the right
Chinese one yeah and like China's great
it's really good I let them invade
that's why they've been infiltrated
that's so [ __ ] funny like everybody's
like first time experience was so what
made your first experience so bad was it
just the longevity the scale what was it
just all of it but then I think it was
worse at the end because I feel like we
weren't on the same page like he was
like damn and then he was like grabbing
a Gatorade as if like he is just like he
needed electrolytes and I'm like are you
doing that's so [ __ ] funny came out
[ __ ] energy he's like damn dude that
was probably the best dick you ever got
[Applause]
so much from so many been like my first
time sucked it was like oh my god like I
said I gave if I could go back in time
and then I would probably tell my former
side do by the way bro you're about to
put your first girlfriend through a
whole year of terrible sex so good luck
we don't come was it great for you cuz
it was amazing for me like it doesn't
take much for a guy to [ __ ] [ __ ] or
even get a boner at that age yeah like I
[ __ ] bend over to tie your shoe and
the guys like ready to bone and then
don't stick it in and top three times
and come dude I couldn't I couldn't even
[ __ ] eat peaches during the summer
because it looked like a fat ass to me
oh you see
we would have some [ __ ] to like you
would even know when I remember this
time this actually happened a lot but
this is one specific time but I was in
my biology class and I [ __ ] knocked
out I took a quick nap in the bell rang
right all right when I woke up I had a
[ __ ] morning wood and I had to sit
there until the [ __ ] boner died and
that and my teacher was like how come
you're not leaving I was like I just
gotta think about a lesson and just go
away go away
so you just what do you do you just sit
until it goes away you should actually
think about like I heard some people
like all people know you got an MD or
empty your mind oh and your mind but
sometimes it has nothing to do with my
cover my dick what a folder and press it
against my pants oh my god and it's like
in your mind it's just like your body
just reacts I'm not even thinking about
dirty [ __ ] I'm like called Nori's and
boners yep it's so annoying
a bunch of team because you get horny
but nothing nothing has to poke out
that's not embarrassing yeah this seems
like a world of trouble
you guys that period so so whatever
gladly do that don't call it a period
anymore my fiance and I get into fights
about this because I like to be a
dramatic [ __ ]
what I'm bleeding I like to call it
actively bleeding sounds a lot more
serious you know it sounds like you get
into a fight over bad terminologies like
babe we get it it happens every month
I'm sorry
let me grab you a midol can I get some
water I'm actively bleeding right now
you're so difficult to deal with good my
god man if I could certainly she's
acting like Jada shut the [ __ ] up kid
and I'll be leaving for three days to
get you a midol and be sweet and do all
this other [ __ ] and protecting you from
giving money to strangers [ __ ] nice
no no he's he's amazing know what he
looks like right yeah I wish it was mine
yeah he's a handsome man just for you
guys you guys are missing out dude he's
a very good boyfriend like I
look at him and I'm like man I can do
better but I don't I could do better
for Jess you know yeah and I'm like man
he's a great he's a great patient man
and I'm like so patient it's kind of
nuts I don't know how he deals but I
would never dare say this on my channel
but he's nice the patience of a [ __ ]
Saint is crazy I don't know how he does
it
I like I don't think that I wanted kids
til I met him
Wow yeah cuz now I'm like you know what
we're in good hands
this is a first yeah cause like I feel
like I would just be crazy could you
imagine my child you're a child so I
can't imagine that right now so it does
not work I hope so
you [ __ ] funny man it's so
interesting cuz like I look at you and
I'm like [ __ ] man was I ever like that
during that age I'm like I probably was
like I think I was like super super at
this [ __ ] it was off the walls
yeah orange oh happy but just very much
off the walls like even when I first met
him eight years ago he wasn't even your
age but this month it was crazy dude and
I found it so funny though he said crack
me so we went meet we met at this San
Diego Asian Film Festival and we're
watching this like Jackie Chan movie and
then like the scroll of just like like
Chinese words came out it's full out of
nowhere in the theater this is a Film
Festival crying out loud he goes oh I
was dying laughing and this white lady
next to me comes up and she goes kid you
tell your quad friend to be quiet I
looked I was like that is not my friend
man it was hilarious
oh my gosh well I did hear that you were
kind of wild I didn't really love you
growing watching up watching up growing
up watching growing up I watched on you
guys didn't love you yeah you started
really enjoying your content once you
got with jazz that's crazy yeah maybe
it's a girl thing too
maybe that's like oh my god he's
man you know so you grew up watching JK
yeah I wouldn't say I was as die-hard
mainly because I don't think that I had
like the same Asian childhood experience
as a lot of Asians dead my mom is really
weird hmm
so I feel like she wasn't like a hundred
percent like a Korean mom or like an
Asian mom so it's like certain things I
would relate really hard and then some
things I'd be like huh what well like my
mom was it like she was strict but in
like really weird things such as like
appearance of course you know and like
being cute but she wasn't a straight
with like great you had an Asian mom
that was more about like a princess
Asian BOM and a lot of Asian moms are
like just straight-up peasants like the
skits where they dress you know and then
they've got the slippers and they're
beating you at the slipper her mom yeah
and my mom's like the type that's like
she won't go anywhere unless she has her
hair and makeup that's like oh that's
like Mario's mom yeah so it's like I
kind of like did relate and then I did
it my mom is actually like more your
mommy
yeah but not not the slippers mom that's
like my mom's slippers mom my mom's the
lady that walks around scratching her
butt and [ __ ] like she's she's a country
bumpkin gay so like your mom and my mom
are like oil and water like so my mom
was yeah like my mom straight-up like
her best friend is my manager who I call
my cousin but we're not really related
like that but we just been seeing each
other since ever but um his mom is very
much like your mom she's you know back
and she's I'll say she's still pretty no
but she always [ __ ] out so she my
like yeah but you know back in the day
she was she's really pretty
very quiet didn't really speak much that
she met my mom right and they became
friends but she was the exact opposite I
remember my mom like just cracking up
and she would say like some like unruly
[ __ ] and then she would just be really
quiet and my mom's like [ __ ] lighten
up and slap her upside the head and [ __ ]
but that's like the type of mom that I
have growing up right so it's just a
complete opposite of yours so what do
you want mariota be mirrors a little bit
of both but she's very I like her
because she's so casual she doesn't
she's not too much of a stickler about
those type of things and there's a
reason why she's with me I she even said
it the other day she goes because I told
her I was like I don't know if you ever
noticed like I always tell us I don't
know if you
notice do you ever really see me look
into a mirror and she goes what do you
mean she goes do you when we go out when
do you ever see me look into America's
you look in the mirror I'll say yeah a
little bit but not really and then when
we were going outside she was looking
you have all this crust on my face she
goes you never look in a mirror like why
don't you I was like because it wasn't
important to my parents so I emulate
what my parents did my mom wasn't very
much about physical looks so neither am
i right so it just never really bothered
me as much so like I don't really had
that so obviously it's different for you
because your mom probably cared about
how you look to everybody else because a
reflection of her yeah she's still wild
yeah no she's just again that dick she's
definitely watching this that she
autoplays my videos so you get that bang
crazy because really how much Adsense am
I really getting from her input not a
lot but she'll use that and leverage it
to get like Chanel bags you know my
sister and I recently got her a car so
and then she's like but I play your [ __ ]
about that stuff she didn't care about
bag she's care about makeup she doesn't
care about jewelry any of that stuff
what does she want just your company she
just wants my company yeah yeah so like
I call my mom like every other day and
so we talk on the phone every other day
maybe almost every day oh my gosh I'm
like so busy like swerving my mom know
why she's my mom's really fun to talk to
so she's just like one of those people
if I'm driving I'm not gonna listen to
music got to talk to my mom
so I'm like what you do today she's like
you know your dad's being an [ __ ] and
my why is he being an [ __ ] and that
we just joke around we laugh we talk
about a bunch of [ __ ] so she probably
talked to her the most not everybody
that I know that's not interesting
because I feel like what I am isn't it
be exact opposite of what like my mom
kind of wanted especially now that I put
all of it out onto the Internet she's
not having like I mean she loves it she
loves the fact that like a lot of people
in the community know me right
but she
like the fact like the type of content
that I did my parents gave up they gave
up okay so you went through that Oh
wants to mold you in an image that's
like DIF that works what she wants with
my fiancee she'll call me and she'd be
like why would you put that on there you
know now people are gonna overlook into
your relationship look at your Chanel
bag and be quiet be quiet
that's why she's not a successful
mukbang person I'm saying you gotta be
real now I would large n eration is
different they love lying and pretending
like [ __ ] that I'm actually gonna I'm
like I want to do a mukbang like some
random thoughts but I wanted to do a
mukbang where I do it in different
characters every [ __ ] that be like
the Korean Adam are like imitation I
when I make a cooking video everybody
asks of food a sock I don't because I do
that there's actually so many Korean I
dream as making mukbangs I would but
then like there's too many [ __ ] agent
dweebs doing that [ __ ] so it annoys me
is the American Muslim community and
like the International one like kind of
connected or is it just called
completely different it's a it's I feel
like the Korean one is still heavily
based on food whereas the American one
is now not so much based on food and
more about like the ocean shoes yeah I
guess it's more entertaining like the
air of like the personality youtubers
right where it's like you watch for the
person and they happen to have food
maybe I should be a month longer with
you that's what I'm saying
I convinced Timothy to make his first
vocal starting fatties are rolling in
you gotta slow down on this shape that
was all me but you work out and you
press you stay packed enough
I think it's awesome jeans know a mic my
mom is a national ping-pong champion
your mom's a gangster yeah we've always
a Korean national ping-pong champion so
she's really fit she has a way better
body than me and she still plays ping
pong like five times a week because she
doesn't to get Alzheimer's I don't know
why that's a fear she's like if I get
Alzheimer's you get there to put me in a
home and I'm gonna hate you she works
out religiously she's she's got a big in
bud okay but um because of that I think
I'm really active it's so funny because
she she thinks that that's gonna prevent
her Alzheimer's you this is a genetic
thing so on top of that to like things
that have been like recorded that helps
it is actually mentally stimulating
things yeah she needs to read a [ __ ]
book yeah she didn't do that in my
grandma has Alzheimer's so why not yeah
be my grandma had Alzheimer's - I'm
pretty sure my parents will get that
unless they choose to stimulate their
mind which I'm trying to get my mom and
stop [ __ ] watching Korean dramas and
read a [ __ ] that's what my grandma's
mind started deteriorating watch [ __ ]
TVs all day yeah dramas are bad yes so I
think I'm very active not just like at
the gym but I'm usually very like I
can't sit still meanwhile sit still for
an entire podcast okay but like I
usually don't like you can fidget either
yeah I haven't calmed down and I'm still
fidgety yeah kind of like you see this
[ __ ] at a Funeral can can't even
sit still I guess it still if I'm not
talking or doing something yeah me too I
can't if I'm just having to sit and
listen
I can't watch shows or like talks I just
drives me [ __ ] crazy Hey it drives me
crazy if I am NOT doing something while
I have a show on I mean I love watching
shows I just can't have that be like 80%
of my attention like movie theaters
stress me out so much because I just
don't know what to do but then also
another stress is I actually like to
Google the ending of the movies before I
go in oh that's you ruin the [ __ ] move
I don't want to get emotionally attached
I'm very sensitive and so I'm like what
if I love this character and they die
that's like literally Google - every
episode
but do you die but it's not even just do
you die it's crazy it's like I want them
to have everything that I wanted so like
if they don't get the guy that they want
I'm like damn and I feel bad ball a
[ __ ] anxiety man smoking weed or some
[ __ ] I did in high school
you should start that up again no I just
did it like 10 years yeah I think so
yeah give it 10 years my mom's not
though my mom bounces off the walls
still maybe it's just in you dude yeah
like she eats standing up she's not a
very like chill person and like she
can't just sit and like sit there and
have a conversation like family dinners
she'll be calling people she'll be
texting people should be standing up and
she'll be doing all definitely eat
standing up too though
I actually enjoy always on the go but
lately I've been learning how to like
chill and breathe he's like I love chili
I'm actually pretty like fidgety to like
I have to stand up I have to move all
the time this is why Papa the only
reason why I do more ties were always
moving yeah like it's always constant
that's why sometimes I hate
weightlifting cuz it's just so like
power lifting of ships not my [ __ ] man I
don't like that stuff but I know how to
focus my energy better like I do fidget
I do [ __ ] never I do stretch myself I
do that but my mind's not thinking in
fragments and I'm more aware so like
before when David probably first met me
I didn't know what I just let it all out
I just I was in I didn't have inner
thoughts I didn't know that people
thought in their head and like didn't
let it I just said yeah if I'm Billy I'm
either I'm either thinking internally if
it's like something I shouldn't say out
loud or I'm just saying it out loud or
my mind is just empty Wow
yeah that's really extreme I don't think
I was ever that bad right I was [ __ ]
bad it wasn't so it was until I feel
like this year that I started waking up
to like oh I should be aware of how I
feel
[Laughter]
he's becoming a full-fledged dog young
even though he's sleeping on a
[ __ ] dude isn't that crazy
I just coughed all over your mic I'm so
it's okay that's what this is what we
take it off we wash it oh do you really
I do
yeah absolutely clear very clean guy
okay so if I licked it would you just be
like angsty well go ahead you I'll
probably sell it on eBay so how long I
mean for them up on thing I feel like
the cool thing about you is I think like
you would thoroughly enjoy what you're
doing so I could be doing this for a
very long time yeah okay so I have two
channels because I decided that I can't
just sit there and like eat just just
that okay here's the thing this is the
worst thing about me I don't know how to
have spare time and so once I get spare
time I will fill it with something else
and so it's just like the weirdest thing
and so I made a second channel which I
do like daily vlogs and like challenges
and just stupid [ __ ] right I feel
like that's like a true my true labor of
love no I love my mug bun-chan thank you
like vlogging but I love that it's my
dream like it just feels a lot more
personal yeah I think you're a specific
type of crazy that where it works out
like it's it's it's true though like I
say it as a joke but you got to be a
little crazy to do that [ __ ] man like
and in the great thing is that you
enjoyed and that's the that's the part
that's gonna keep you doing this for a
very long time there's like certain
youtubers that we know they do it out of
like their their motive to want to do
this was already in a bad place and they
already they're they're burnt out you
know they wanted they like I want to do
this because I want [ __ ] girls to
[ __ ] me or some [ __ ] like that and
there's some some people like that right
now they feel this type of pressure and
they they're like lost because even
though they got all these millions of
subscribers they forgot that they're
still ugly as [ __ ] nobody likes them and
it's like that's not gonna change like
no matter what you know like those those
that clout chasing stuff doesn't fulfill
something that you need in your life
right yeah well I feel like people can
tell I feel like the viewers are so
smart and I feel like they like
subconsciously can tell because you did
you know about the horror movies I'm
sure like you have a bajillion things
more than I do about this but like
oh you doin I love horror movies okay I
love death I love murder I love true
crime and I love horror and so horror
movies they do this thing that just it's
small things that nobody notices it's
not part of the plot but it's like these
small things that they do just to like
have the viewers slightly imbalanced and
so what they'll do is like they'll set
the time in the back like a clock that
just doesn't Majan it doesn't
continuously flow and so in your brain
you don't realize you don't see oh I
caught that clock it says 302 when it's
not 302 in the movie right now right but
it's just it you absorb all of that and
then it puts you off balance something
feels off about the whole movie because
of these small little shifts that they
do and I feel like it's the same with
youtubers like I feel like if you're
really not into it like people are gonna
tell even if you're like hey I love you
know yeah but that's just my thoughts
unless you're 12
nobody yeah you just don't see through
it but yeah you're an adult a lot of
people sense it yeah but you're right
about the energy stuff if you're not
authentically people read it people get
it you know oh yeah for sure yeah so
what's that what's the horror movie that
you really like I love all of them but I
love them well oh you like to death like
just like a strip murders and uh and
then you're just like the sweet persona
well I love true crime more so I love
like documentaries oh my god in plain
sight on Netflix have you seen it no to
go watch it it's pretty much a family
friend who kidnaps an underage girl
multiple times marries her like assaults
her it's but like it happens in plain
sight like and she gets kidnapped taken
across the border to Mexico and her
parents know exactly who took her i
watch that yeah but what's even crazier
is this dude slept with both of her
parents oh is this the holy hold up yeah
dude that had another guy at his car and
he got that guy to give him a [ __ ]
yeah dad was the funniest thing I've
ever heard of he was like he recognized
that the dad was gay yeah can you slept
with them he slept with the wife he
slept with the kids it's crazy
what I [ __ ] G yes so I love things
like that like I love just dark things I
like Korean horror films though Oh or
thrillers okay like have you seen uh
ahkamaat a poet ah that one's called
I saw the devil one of my favorites I
can't okay
it's weird I like dark but I saw one
dark Korean thriller oldboy is an old
boy same director as uh oh
and I was so traumatized why cuz he
fluxes yes I was like this is I don't
want to say it but a little too dark you
know it's actually one of my favorite
films oh boy yeah just like it's a
really good story wise cinematography
beyond Korean Korean cinema because
before that I didn't know that it
existed yeah yeah no I like more of like
the um like a Ted Bundy yeah like the
Ted Bundy like mystery murders yeah like
why do they want to kill me oh just
watch I saw the devil I saw the devil
okay okay so it's less like old boy it's
crazy
it really is and I just feel like I know
how they didn't know because people like
you naive as [ __ ] like people are nice
you know they find these nice human
beings that they take advantage of it so
I'm telling you you might get [ __ ]
happy giving people hand jobs out of
nowhere just like that other guy's like
well you know I'm just really tired if
you just [ __ ] just whack me off real
quick I might get a job
to do with the student loan oh that's
like even my mom thinks I got so lucky
that I met my fiancee young because I
get the other like spectrum of it where
everyone's like oh like you want to
settle down so young like I can't
believe you're engaged why you know just
wait but I I feel like I'm like without
him I would have just probably been in a
ditch somewhere
well a lot of people don't get a chance
to actually be in real love and also
commit yeah I think that's the thing is
that people are just afraid to commit
right so when you're young you're like
well I don't know if they're the one I
still want to like test the waters
mm-hmm I don't believe in the one I
don't either but that's a lot of people
say yeah like the one like I don't think
the only one yeah I think like everyone
can be the one not me I see I I actually
believe that they leave a plane to the
one but I also believe in the fact that
once I'm with somebody I committed this
amount of time you best believe I'm not
gonna redo that again yeah yeah yeah
I'll be single for the rest of my life
and I'll just get random [ __ ] and I'm
okay because I am NOT rebuilding
something I've rebuilt like 7 8 10 years
and icicle to actually to [ __ ] it again
cuz your dad go through so many
arguments no time why would you do
that's not doing that what it's like the
people that keep getting divorced and
married and divorced and married it's
gonna be the same thing they think that
the next one will be different
oh because you're that [ __ ] stupid a
personal issue that they're not dealing
with themselves and so it's just a cycle
as repetitious so if you're not gonna
fix these problems now with a person
that you're with then it's just gonna go
to the next person you know it's gonna
manifest in different ways also I saw
you at Gina's party so I said
congratulations already oh yeah we
didn't film it did it really happen
that's right that's right
yeah that's right huh look at that
Gina's birthday party I came dressed the
best commit everybody did yes you did
and he came in with a backpack with a
bottle of Dom inside it and he just
pulled it I was like what is happy yeah
I'm the life of the party homey that's
what it is yeah but to be honest with
you Isis didn't read the invite and I
did this guy and
just know that it was like the death so
I said oh maybe I should wear something
black yes I know I just didn't know yeah
yeah no her party was wild yeah it was
pretty good and I didn't even drink it
it was wild
you don't drink it all no I get very red
the very tomato and the beer will knock
me out oh okay yeah and so I just don't
want to be someone else's miss you know
cuz I get real messy
well that wraps up this podcast what
kind of what kind of killing it today
dude that's easy hour and ten minutes
party when Stephanie's around Oh for
those people who don't know who you are
how can they find you
I'm Stephanie sue on YouTube and miss
manga bye miss manga but you could check
her out on those she's a mukbang her
she's a lifestyle she's super fun to
watch and give her a give her a give her
a shout-out in a check out to be super
fun man you guys can find us on iTunes
and give us that five star on that
youtube comment below ask Stephanie some
damn questions man get to get to know or
see what's up
stitcher Spotify everything else genius
brain that's genius brain one
[ __ ] word I am David so that's
Joe Jitsu Kawa and that Stephanie Susu
but do do like that smash that like
button vibes as a Mar [ __ ] Wow